She could KO Trump. All right, Trump will never be caught dead
in a room alone with Marjorie Taylor Green. She would pull his
hands off like the chimpanzeee she is. All right, it would go
horrible for him. Do you guys see just the open gaslighting that
happens all of the time? [laughter]
I never I've never done that. Jewish space lasers. Who said that?
So, probably going to do that first. Was this yesterday or the
day before? I think the day before, right? Yep. The day before
Trump came out and said he he tweeted out in the in the afternoon.
I guess this is after Marjorie Taylor Green kept pushing she
couldn't be cowed from pushing for the release of the Epstein
files. All right. I am withdrawing my support and endorsement
of Congresswoman Congresswoman quote
Butch Lesbian Marjgerie Taylor Green of the great state of Georgia.
Over the past few weeks, despite my creating record achievements
for our country, including a total and complete victory on the
shutdown, closed borders, low taxes, no men and women sports,
or transgender for everyone, or transgender for everyone. [laughter]
That was the Democrat policy. They're running on transgender
for everyone.
Ending ending DEI, stopping. Okay. All these rebuilding the military.
K. All right. Oddest country anywhere in the world from being
a dead country just 12 months ago and so much more. All I see
is wacky Marjgery do. All I see my wacky Marjorie do is complain,
complain, complain. It seemed to all begin when I sent her a
poll stating that she should not run for senator or governor.
She was at 12% and didn't have a chance. Unless, of course, she
had my endorsement, which she wasn't about to get. She had told
many people that she is upset that I don't return her phone calls
anymore. But with 219 Congressw men/women, 53 senators, and 24
cabinet members, almost 200 countries, and an otherwise normal
life to lead,
no, you don't have a normal life to lead. You're the president.
You don't have a life. You're literally the president. Shut up.
He's like, I I I have to do a lot of golfing, okay? My golf game
has suffered tremendously for this country. And Marjorie doesn't
even care.
I can't take a ranting lunatics call every day. I understand
that wonderful conservative people are thinking about primary
Marjorie in her district of Georgia, and that they too are fed
up with her and her antics, and if the right person runs, they
will have my complete and unwielding support. She has gone far
left even doing the view with their low IQ Republican hating
anchors. Thank you for your attention to this matter. Make America
great again. Okay, he went super hard Mar on MTG. Okay,
let's see.
This is the next day. All right, we have to keep going with some
of his uh MTG hate. All right, lightweight Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Brown. Green grass turns brown when it begins to rot.
Dude, this is like [laughter]
he's having like an actual aneurysm when he tweets these things.
Okay.
Marjorie Taylor Brown,
green grass turns brown when it begins to rot. Betrayed the entire
Republican party when she turned left, performed poorly on the
pathetic view, and became the rhino that we all know she always
was. Just another fake politician, no different than Rand Paul
Jr., Thomas Massie, who got caught being a full-fledged Republican
and name only. Make America great again. It's literally he's
just taking hits out on all of the people who are supporting
releasing the Epstein files. That's like the entirety of it,
isn't it? It's like very obvious. You're pushing for the Epstein
file release. Uh you are a fake Republican. You don't want to
protect. You are a fake Republican. You're a fake Republican.
You're a rhino. Only
Only Rhinos can't get behind our message, guys. Only rhinos.
That's how it is. That's all it is. That'll be all it is for
the near foreseeable future. He gave Clinton a [__]
It seems Listen, many people are saying this. Okay, many people
are saying this. We got one more.
Same warning. Marjorie Trader Green is a disgrace to our great
Republican party. Somebody must have told them to call her Marjgery
Trader Green, right? Somebody must have said it to him cuz I
I swear to God the Marjgery Taylor Brown is just it was never
going to cut it. All right. Ever ever
on. Bubba palette cleanser. Just give me a second. What is this?
>> Nut
going guac
on his brother. Playing that like a saxophone. Presidential top
while they're all alone. Don't give a about Hillary. Donald Trump
blow it up like a wall three. Trump suck bills his big old belly
from the
dude. AI was a mistake. All right.
Every everything in AI everything was a mistake. All a mistake.
Mother of God.
All right. Let's see. We've got
then we've got MTG responding. And I think there's more stuff
from today. So, I'll take a look at some of the stuff from today
as well. Okay. MTG says, "I'm now being contacted by private
security firms with warnings for my safety as a hot bed of threats
against me are being fueled and egged on by the most powerful
men in the world. The man I supported and helped get elected.
Aggressive rhetoric attacking me is historically led to the to
death threats and multiple convictions of men who are radicalized
by the same type of rhetoric being directed at me right now."
Wait, what?
People who hate me have always hated me and have become aggressive
towards me. Okay. They get they get radicalized by people hating
me.
This time by the president of the United States. As a woman,
I take threats from men seriously. I now have a small un Bro,
your biceps are bigger than Trump's. You absolutely can bench
more than Trump. Okay. Oh, it's a little tiny bean. Is a It's
just a widow bean woman. No. Shut up. Shut up. How many pull
How many pull-ups can Trump do? Like zero.
Obviously zero. Why are you acting like this guy's a big imposing
threat? She could KO Trump. All right. Trump will never be caught
dead in a room alone with Marjorie Taylor Green. She would pull
his hands off like the chimpanzeee she is. All right. It would
go horrible for him. He would die. All right.
She She'd just start pulling limbs off of him. Okay. Like a silverback
in the Oval Office.
She's talking about his followers. She
I now have a small understanding of the fear and pressure the
women who are victims of Jeffrey Epstein as Cabal must feel as
a Republican who overwhelmingly votes for President Trump's bills
and agenda. His aggression towards or against me, which also
fuels the venomous nature of his radical internet trolls, many
of whom are paid. This is completely shocking to everyone. My
phone is blowing up with constant amazing support. I'm so thankful.
The political industrial complex and the toxic violent nature
of American politics must end. Our country is worth saving, and
it can only be done if we pull together to save ourselves. I
never thought leopards would eat my face. Sobs women who voted
for the leopards eating people's faces party
little bit MTG
classic. Okay, hold on. One more tweet. One more tweet.
I think this one's different. Hold on. Okay, this one is from
today. No, this is still yesterday. President Trump just attacked
me and lied about me. I haven't called him at all, but I did
send text messages today. Apparently, this is what sent him over
the edge. The Epstein files. And of course, he's coming after
me hard to make an example to scare all the other Republicans
before next week's vote to release the Epstein files. It's astonishing
how hard he's fighting to stop the Epstein files from coming
out that he actually goes to this level. But really, most Americans
wish he would fight this hard to help the forgotten men and women
of America who are fed up with foreign wars and foreign causes
and are going broke trying to feed their families and are losing
hope of ever achieving the American dream. That's what I voted
for. I have supported President Trump with too much of my precious
time, too much of my own money, and fought harder for him, even
when almost all of the Republicans turned their back and denounced
him. But I don't worship or serve Donald Trump. I worship God.
Jesus is my savior, and I serve the my district, Georgia 14,
and the American people. I remain the same today as I've always
been, and I will continue to pray this administration will be
successful because the American people desperately deserve what
they voted for. For me, I remain America first and America only.
Hold on a second. EJT, check the flight logs of Epstein's plane.
Bill Clinton is on there on there like 26 times. Hillary 2. For
many of us releasing, the Epstein files have has always been
for the women who were victims of Jeffrey Epstein, but also because
we believe that Democrat bad guys like the Clintons were entertain
were entangled
and involved with him. Epste was the spider that wo the web of
the deep state. Lean into it.
The Jeffrey Epstein hoax.
In every single interview I've done, I've defended President
What is this other? What is this? Natalie NH. What?
What is this? Sorry, she did see CNN interview today.
>> Oh, she's totally out. Unfortunate.
>> It's the political breakup heard around the world. President
Trump severing ties with his at least one of his closest allies,
declaring, "I am withdrawing my support and endorsement of Congresswoman
Marjgerie Taylor Green, even calling for primary challenges against
his one-time loyalist and attacking her as quote wacky, a ranting
lunatic, a rhino, and a traitor." This is days before the House
of Representatives is set to vote. >> Oh, Natalie Harper
is the chick who writes his tweets and hoaxes. Oh, okay. vote
on releasing the Epstein files. It's a stunning breach between
two MAGA leaders, one of whom is here with me now exclusively
for her first interview since the president cut ties. Republican
Congresswoman Marjgerie Taylor Green of Georgia. Thank you so
much for being here. As you just heard, and I know you saw, the
president says he's withdrawing support for >> Oh, real
quick before we check this out, I'll just check one more MTG
tweet about her getting harassed, cuz this might help us explain
why
she's now throwing in the towel if she does. So, like people
are saying, the hoax pizza deliveries have started now to my
house and my family members. Update. We also received a pipe
bomb threat on my construction company's office building. President
Trump's unwarranted and vicious attacks against me were a dog
whistle to dangerous radicals that could lead to serious attacks
on me and my family. Unfortunately, I've been down this road
before. As a matter of fact, as I campaigned all over the country
and defended President Trump, I received dozens of swatting calls
on my house in my family members homes along with these hoax
pizza deliveries. But even more severely, I have received some
of the mo some of the most death threats I've received some of
the most death threats.
Some of the most Okay. of any member of Congress. Uhhuh.
the tweets after the interview. Okay.
>> for you then uh encouraging primary challengers. You
were one of his biggest supporters. It's >> some of the
most >> What do you think? >> Some of the most of
I Okay. >> happened here. >> Well, Dana, thank you
for having me on. And that >> she must have meant like
some of the most egregious death threats or something. That's
what she must have meant. But she didn't say that. She said some
of the most death threats. It >> is true. Um, I I stood
with President Trump when virtually no one else did. Campaigned
all over the country, spent millions of my own dollars helping
him get elected. And I think that's incredibly important. And
I do support him and his administration. And I support them in
delivering the campaign promises we made to the American people.
>> This reminds me of Elon actually, right? How how do
these people keep calling Trump? They're like Trump's a and then
and then they see their numbers go down. and they see like favorability
drop for them and they're like, "Wait, wait, wait, wait. I've
always supported him
How do you just call this guy and then go crawling back? It's
it's wild." >> His remarks of course have been hurtful.
Um, however, I I have something in my heart that I think is incredibly
important for our country and that is to end the toxic fighting
in politics and this has been going on for years and it has divided
our country. >> Okay. I think I dude
this again is just like Gerbles appears one day on on German
television. He's like, "Guys, I've been saying this for so long.
We must end the persecution of in this country. We It's got to
end. I've been saying it forever. We must end persecution of
in 1938
Germany." Okay? We must end the persecution. We cannot keep doing
it's like, "Brother, you are like you are you are the general.
You are the person. You you are the person who's like most done
this. You are the most toxic combative person in the Republican
party or that's been your reputation forever.
What are you saying?
>> Split up friends and families
um neighbors and it's not solving our problems. Um the most hurtful
thing he said which is absolutely untrue is he called me a traitor.
And that is that is so extremely wrong. I can't I just can't
take this seriously for Marjorie Taylor Green. This is like she
is
objectively a silverback gorilla. She does not know how to back
down from a fight. She only knows how to fight. She's the most
masculine member of Congress. And when she goes, "I'm just a
woman who's very scared of these big scary men." Nobody believes
you. You could literally pull their fingers off one at a time
while holding them down with the other hand. Okay? Nobody believes
you that you're scared. Stop saying it. Stop pretending you're
scared. You just don't like that you're losing. That's it. Okay.
>> Wrong. And those are the types of words um used that
can radicalize people against me and put my life in danger. >> What
do you think happened? What do you think is the reason for this?
>> I'll be real. If you guys don't know, can you imagine
Loomer doing this? I can because they're both the same kind of
totally unprincipled loser. But what I can't imagine right now,
Rhox, is how hard Fuentes is going to be crowing tonight. Cuz
MTG is one of the people. Do you remember when Tucker was like,
"Can't you just forgive Marjorie Taylor Green?" You guys remember
that in the interview with Tucker? He was like, "You got to forgive
Marjorie Taylor Green." Plentto's going to go live tonight and
just be like, "I told you this was the
It's going to be a great time." Okay, I don't know when I don't
know if he goes live tonight. I don't know if he's going to be
But whenever he comments on this, okay, it's going to be good.
I know it.
Unfortunately, it has all come down to the Epstein files. And
that is shocking. And you know, I I stand with these women. I
stand with rape victims. I stand with children who are in terrible
abuse situations. And I stand with survivors of of trafficking
and those that are trapped in
trafficking. And I I will not apologize for that. I I believe
the country deserves transparency in these files. And I I don't
believe that that rich powerful people should be protected if
they have if they have done anything wrong. And and so I'm standing
with the women and I will continue to do my small part to get
the files released. >> You said on X yesterday, quote,
"It's astonishing really how hard he's fighting to stop the Epstein
files from coming out and that it really makes you wonder what
is in those files. Are you suggesting there's something in the
Epstein file? [laughter] >> Now she's going to play stupid.
Now she's going to play stupid when she's trying to make it seem
like Trump is absolutely scared of what's in those >> That
President Trump doesn't >> No, I'd never suggest that President
Trump had something in those. I'd never do that. I'd never call
the Get out of >> Not want Americans. >> Get out
of town.
>> Well, I think that's the part that has so many people
confused is that the women themselves that I have talked to have
over and over again said that Donald Trump did nothing wrong.
Um, quite a few of them even told me they voted for him. And
those are the women I would like to see in the Oval Office uh
with support. I would like to see all of the women there with
support. Um, I have no idea what's in the files. I I can't even
guess, but that is the questions everyone is asking is why fight
this so >> Well, before this blow up, you you sort of alluded
to this just now. You said you were confident the president would
>> Well, well,
well,
wait, hold on. What is
Some commentary on MTG right now.
>> Oh, yeah. We saw this when it came out. Or wait, no,
this is a different one. I could have sworn he'd said this before
that he'd be willing to work with. >> So, what happened
next in the saga? Well, Marjorie got her committee assignments,
but her sugar daddy Kevin McCarthy is out of a job. He lost the
gavl
in the government shutdown in I think it was September 2023.
He lost the speakerhip and then he resigned from Congress and
Mike Johnson came into power. So now Marjorie lost her sugar
daddy. Now the deal is no longer good. Well, she still is seeking
higher office. She wants to rebrand. She was the MAGA mom hillbilly.
She tried to rebrand as a political operator. I did what needed
to be done. I made a deal with McCarthy. I got my assignments.
I sold out cuz I'm a boss now. I'm someone you can make a deal
with. But her sugar daddy got fired. So, the deal backfired.
And Marjorie was still looking to be the governor of Georgia
or the senator from Georgia. But you know what the party leadership
told her? They said, "Uh-uh. Ain't going to happen. You can never
win." Marjorie wanted to run for governor. They said, "No, you
can't win. You're too crazy." She said, "Well, I want to run
for senator." No, you can't. You're too crazy.
Wait, when did Trump tweet this?
Hold on. That was like Trump's initial message, too. Was like,
"No, you can't run for these these higher offices."
Where is this? Where is this?
This all began when I sent her a poll stating she can't be like
the governor or senator in Georgia because she's at
Okay. I can't tell if this is Nick echoing or Trump echoing Nick.
I can't tell which one would be crazy or which one would be crazier.
Well, obviously, sorry. Obviously, if it was Trump echoing Nick,
that would be insane. Anyway, we >> complicated. Are you
still confident of >> I can go back to the Nick clip in
just a little bit. We got to get through this.
>> I I'm listening to the women. Those are the ones that
are saying that he did nothing wrong. Uh Virginia Dup Fray even
said under oath that Donald Trump did nothing wrong and she wrote
it in her book. So I'm continuing to listening to the women and
I think >> uh she didn't just cancel the affac appearance.
Rhox, she also like attacked him personally. She she literally
hired Milo Yiannopoulos was letting Milo stay in her house. She
let Milo use I I think the allegation from Gropers, I don't know
if this ended up coming out or if it got investigated was that
she was paying Milo and Milo was doing like oppo research on
Nick because Nick kept attacking her. like she hire she hired
Nick's mortal enemy to come and do like basically I don't know
oppo propaganda against him. >> Their voices should be
the loudest. >> The president said the reason that you
have been critical of him is not necessarily Epstein but because
he pushed you not to run for the Senate or for governor in Georgia.
How and when did he do that?
>> Well, that is absolutely not true. Actually, I never
had a conversation at all with the president about running for
Senate or running for Georgia. And those were decisions I came
to on my own that I I don't want to have anything to do with
the Senate. I think the past two months of the government shutdown
should have shown America um exactly why I would never want to
be there. I think it's a very broken institution that serves
the uni party and doesn't serve the American people and how they
vote. And I decided um that I didn't want to run uh for governor
this cycle either. I >> I thought it was all the Milo thing
Koser, but thank you for the >> much want to do the job
that I'm in. Everyone else says I'm running for something, but
all I want to do is serve uh Georgia's 14th district and um I'm
very grateful for that opportunity. >> So he said it pretty
explicitly. Are you saying he's lying or did he at least uh get
that message to somebody on your political team instead? >> I'm
I'm not sure. I But I don't he that is untrue what he said. I
don't know if he's being fed wrong information. Um I I honestly
have no idea in that area, but it is absolutely factually not
true, nor have I called him and White House logs would prove
that. His own cell phone records would prove it. I have not been
calling the president, but I did post um messages that I had
sent to him and um that was to like protect, you know, get involved.
This is important. The American people want the Epstein files
released. And you know, I've stood with the president. I have
disagreed with him at times, Dana, and I'm allowed to do that.
I think that's that's the most important thing we can do as Americans.
And I'm urging my party. I've been putting massive pressure on
my party and our speaker to pass the agenda that the American
people vote for. That's the agenda that I fought for. Those are
the campaign promises I made. And I can disagree with the president
at times, especially particularly this past Monday on the Marine
250th anniversary when he honored the new Syrian president who
is an al-Qaeda terrorist and was wanted by our government for
years with a $10 million bounty up until March of this year.
I very much am against that. I think that was um very hurtful
to the great men and women who served over in the Middle East
and were sent there and many of them that were killed and and
injured and live with PTSD to this day from fighting al-Qaeda.
So, there's things I disagree with and I'm allowed to do so.
>> Well, you mentioned the Syrian uh leader at the White
House. You've also been critical of President Trump over foreign
entanglements, H-1B visas. Now, he's moving military assets towards
Venezuela. I do want to play something that he said this week.
[snorts] >> Don't forget, MAGA was my idea. MAGA was nobody
else's idea. I know what MAGA wants better than anybody else.
And MAGA wants to see our country thrive. >> Do you agree?
Do you think he represents the MAGA movement as he once did?
>> Well, what the American people voted for with MAGA was
to put the American people first and stop sending foreign aid
and stop being involved in foreign wars. They very much deserve
to be put for first. Cost of living is far too high. Health insurance
is completely out of control. And that's those are two issues
I have been very vocal on for months and months now, long before
Republicans were shocked when those big losses came on this past
Tuesday's election. So, I think that the American people deserve
to be put first. That's what Make America Great again um rep
meant to me. Um and and I think that President Trump can do that
if he refocuses his effort and I think that's what I want to
see. I think that's what the country wants to see. Um even if
he's attacking me, I do want him to be successful for the American
people. >> So you're sounds like you're saying that he
is not representing the mega movement that he started right now.
>> I can say that um promoting H-1B visas to to replace
American jobs. Um bringing in 600,000 Chinese students to replace
American students opportunities in American college. >> Wait,
are they replacing Chinese? Wait, are they replacing American
students with Chinese ones? what >> colleges and universities,
those are not America first positions. And continuing to um really
travel all over the world doesn't help Americans back at home.
I I really and I said this uh to him and I and I will say it
out loud. I would love to see Air Force One be parked and stay
home and there be nothing but a constant focus in the White House
on a domestic agenda that helps the American people once and
for all. >> Congresswoman, you posted on X that President
Trump is with his comments fueling a quote hotbed of threats
against you. Obviously any threats to your safety are completely
unacceptable. But we have seen these kinds of attacks or criticism
from the president at other people. It's not [laughter]
>> why why is this such a big deal for you? Don't you think
don't you think about the other people who have had to deal with
his eyeire in the the previous, you know, months, years? Why
do you think this is just you? Why is this suddenly such a big
deal? You've supported him through all of his attacks, very similar
attacks on other people. >> Not new. And with respect,
I haven't heard you speak out about it until it was directed
at you, Dana. And I think that's fair criticism and I would like
to say humbly I'm sorry for taking part in the toxic uh politics.
It's it's very bad for our country. Um and I' it's been something
I've thought about a lot. >> Ain't no [__]
way.
Where is she even going with this line of like rhetoric? Where
the is she going with what is the point of you? What is your
point? The only thing that you became famous for was being the
toxic like Trump pugilist who would fight with anybody who disagreed
with Trump. That's your brand. You're just basically
This is
What are we doing? What What are you doing? >> Especially
since Charlie Kirk was assassinated is that we I'm >> Hold
on. You guys can only think this is good messaging
if you think she has a lane she's going into. What lane is she
going into? Is there a party that's purely America first with
zero toxicity with everybody being nice to each other? Does that
exist somewhere in some other country in some other universe?
Who is she going to with this? >> Only responsible for
myself and my own words and actions. And I am going I am committed
and I've been working on this a lot lately to put down the knives
and politics. I really just want to see people be kind to one
another. And we need to figure out a new path forward that is
>> I'm sorry. I can't help
I hope Lav isn't watching. Okay, I hope Lav isn't watching, but
this is how I I feel like this is how I feel when Lav's like,
I I don't want to be mean to anybody anymore. [laughter] This
is like the same thing. It's the exact same.
Like, [laughter]
Brand is mean. What are you talking about? What are you saying?
Who are you if you don't do this? If you say this. No, but I
actually I like Lav. Okay, Lav is there's a nice person inside
of Lav who can like hurt people sometimes, but there is a nice
person in there somewhere. Okay. Who I like
it can be challenging for me to sometimes, but like she's she's
like I think there's some there's something there. Okay. I understand
how other people dislike parts of Lav, but like a there's there's
a part of her that's like a good person. I think God, I don't
even know about reading people on the internet anymore. Okay.
I feel like there is. Anyway, MTG, it's just like totally counter
to the brand, right? That's the thing.
uh everybody who thinks this is like MTG the MTG is doing good
political messaging here. I don't think you're correct. I don't
I think this is totally >> Focused on the American people
because as Americans, no matter what side of the aisle we're
on, we have far more in common than we have differences and we
need to be able to respect each other with our disagreements.
So just >> No, no, no, no. Porter Beller Tucker doesn't
say he didn't mean it like that. He goes, "What are you talking
about? I never said anything like that. What are you talking
about? You're totally insane." Him and Candace do the same thing.
It's not even like I was angry. It's just like I'm just going
to straight up gaslight. Yeah, I realize I put that out on video.
I realize that there's a transcript to that video. I realize
I'm openly lying. No, no, no. I didn't Are you insane? Are you
[laughter] totally [__] crazy?
Are you Are you out of your mind? I [laughter] didn't say that
>> on this. You regret the things that you >> Wait,
when did I say Christian Zionists are like the worst people and
it's a Christian heresy? I never said that. What are you talking
about? What are you? I never went to Moscow. I didn't interview
Putin. What the What are you talking about? I don't even know
what you're talking about. >> Said and posted in the past
the Facebook uh post that was taken down of you in 2020 holding
a gun alongside the squad encouraging people to go on the offense
against the socialists, liking a tweet of somebody calling for
the execution of Nancy Pelosi and former President Obama. Just
examples. >> Well, Dana, as you know and many people know,
I addressed that back in 2021 and of course um I never want to
cause any harm or anything bad for anyone. So that that was addressed
back then and I very much stand by my words I said then and I
stand by my words today. I think America needs to come together
and end all the toxic dangerous rhetoric and divide and I'm leading
the way with my own example and I hope that President Trump can
do the same. >> Okay. So on that I do want to ask you about
something you posted just yesterday on X. You questioned who
and what country is putting so much pressure on Trump to keep
the Epstein files hidden and you included a picture about donations
from pro-Israel lobbying group Apac. What are you trying to say
there?
Oh, wait, [laughter] wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. Hold on. What? What does this mean? What is
this? Is this like uh What did you mean here? This is, by the
way,
notice Dana Bash actually doing the correct thing. I'm not going
to say you're like an anti-semite, but you put Okay, this is
this in the Epste files is why I'm being attacked by President
Trump. It really makes you wonder what is what in those files
and who in what country is putting so much pressure on him. I
forgive him and I will pray for him to return to his original
manga promises. Okay. Liberty score. Lindsay, sorry, Marjgery
Taylor Green. A Lindsey Graham. F.
Marjgery Taylor Green takes no money from Israel, huh? Hey, hey,
hey, MTG. What are you you implying something here? >> And
you included a picture about donations from pro-Israel lobbying
group APAC. What are you trying to say there? Well, I think it's
a question that many Americans are asking, especially when we
saw information recently come out in these emails that uh the
oversight committee that I serve on has released and we saw Jeffrey
Epstein with ties to Ahoud Barack. Um we saw him making business
deals with them, also business deals that involved the the Israeli
government um and and seems to have led into their intel uh agencies.
And I think the right question is to ask is was Jeffrey Epstein
um working for Israel? And I'm I'm proud to say I don't take
money from Apac. I don't take money from any special um group
of people. I'm I'm just representing my district and the American
people. And so that's what I was referring to. I just want to
be clear. Are you [laughter] >> Oh, no. Dana. Dana, just
let her listen. She's just saying, "Hey, taking So your position
is that like taking money from any lobbyist group is bad. That's
your position. You're not There's not like a specific intention
with pointing out Israel here. >> You saying Israel is
pushing the president of the United States to cover up the Epstein
files. And what evidence do you have that that is?" >> No,
I simply No, I simply asked. No, I simply just asked. No, I just
think it's an important question for the American people to ponder.
Okay, I didn't claim it. I just asked I didn't claim that it
was happening. I was just saying, you know, I think the American
people should think about whether or not
duplicitus. Okay, I just think that's something that's on the
American mind. It's in the zeitgeist. Okay, are trustable in
any way? I just I didn't say they're not trust. You can trust
them. I trust some. Not many, but some. Okay. And I'm just asking,
should the American people trust a country that is almost 60
people >> asked out loud, uh, is there a foreign government?
It could be any foreign government, but is a foreign government?
>> I think is it 80? I don't actually know the ethnic makeup
of Israel, to be honest with you. >> Pushing to keep this
covered up because people just don't understand, um, the the
big fight against >> Well, you had Apac up there. It was
pretty clear which government you were talking about. >> We've
got a new Trump. >> I'm questioning that government in
particular and questioning any other foreign government. >> Okay.
um when you you're talking about uh lowering the rhetoric, which
is important for for everybody to hear from you and all of our
uh elected officials, but there is some concern a lot of concern
among Republicans about the rise of anti-semitic hard-right figures
in your movement, especially >> Oh, do you disavow
Mr. Fuentes?
Do you disavow him? What about Tucker? >> After Tucker
Carlson hosted white nationalist Nick Fuentes on his podcast,
didn't question Fuentes about his vile language or views. You
did speak at a conference hosted by Fuentes back in 2022. You
were criticized and you said then that you didn't know about
his views. Well, Fland has talked to Carlson about that in the
interview. Listen to what he said.
>> Well, again with Marjorie, I was a friend of hers and
she spoke at my conference and then the day after she pretended
like she didn't know me. She pretended like she didn't know me
and lied and said I had no idea the conference I was speaking
at. She knew exactly what it was. >> I don't even know
who that person is. Dude, I I didn't realize the hidden tech
of like every influencer of every political operative is to just
lie openly
and rely on people who are like have some interest in covering
it for you and have some who have some interest in like obiscating
for you. You just lie all the time. Okay. Just lie about everything.
I have no idea what you're talking about. Uh I don't recall.
>> What do you say to that? Well, first of all, I defend
every single person's free speech rights. I think that's incredibly
important. So, I don't apologize that for that. And I don't believe
in cancelling people. And I think it's important for people like
Tucker Carlson and yourself to interview everyone. Um I I don't
believe in in trying to cancel someone by refusing to interview
them and question them. And um I I did speak at his conference
back in 2022. However, I don't know Nick Fuentes. Um he's someone
I've never exchanged text messages with or phone calls, but I
did speak at his his conference. That was the first time I had
met him uh that day and and and that was it. But I did watch
the interview. I watched the full interview with Tucker and and
I admire him for interviewing many people as as well as exposing
a lot of powerful >> I hear what you're saying on I hear
what you're saying about free speech. I mean countly as guilty
as a proponent of free speech. There's free speech and then there
is hate speech and this is a man uh invited on a really prominent
>> wait is that in the constitution that there's free speech
and hate speech? Is that a part of the first amendment that there's
like free speech and then hate speech?
I could have sworn that this was America. I could have sworn
that we're in America. Okay. I I don't remember them putting
hate speech in the Constitution.
I thought this was
>> Conservative show who said even during that interview,
he had a problem with quote organized jewelry and he wasn't challenged
on it. >> I don't even know who this guy is. I don't even
know. I I had no idea who this guy was. I don't know anything
about this guy. Who Who the [__] is this guy? I don't
know who this guy is. Don't try to tie me to this guy.
>> In the past, he has denied the Holocaust. Called Adolf
effing cool. Dude, I just I feel like they don't
that quoting that line, as bad as it is, for the average person
when they hear that term organized,
they Google organized. And I don't know what comes up on Google
for sure when you enter that in, but I feel like it's not good.
I feel like you're sending people down a rabbit hole whenever
you use that like totally outlandish term that's been completely
off of every major news network for decades,
right? I don't know if they understand that when you put that
word in, you're probably sending people down some kind of pipeline.
They don't understand. >> Talked about the fact that he
thought Jim Crow was just fine and on and on. So, again, there
is there's free speech and then there's just hateful language
and sentiments. Well, Dana, again, um I I told you on this this
interview that I'm committed to ending the toxic politics and
I think uh I don't want to have anything to do with it. Um you
should have Nick Fentis on your show and you could ask him questions
about that. I myself am not anti-Semitic. I have never criticized
um the people or said anything about them in particular. I am
critical of their the government. >> Wait, what what were
the space lasers about? I've never I've never said See, do you
guys see Do you guys see just the open gaslighting that happens
all of the time? I never I've never done that. Jewish space lasers.
Who said that? Wait, what are you talking about? You're crazy.
You're just making You're crazy. I think you might need like
some medication cuz you're crazy. Where do you get this stuff?
>> Government of Israel. And I can criticize any government
I want to um in the entire world as well as our own. And a lot
of the times I'm criticizing our own government for failing the
American people. And I think that needs to be the focus and that's
the most important thing people care about is being able to afford
groceries, housing, health insurance and having >> go back
20 seconds. Okay, hold on.
Go back 20 seconds here to do with it. Um you should have Nick
Fentis on your show and you could ask him questions about that.
I myself am not anti-Semitic. I have never criticized um the
people or said anything about them in particular. I am critical
of their the government of Israel and I can criticize >> of
their government of of the government of their government
and then she corrected to the the government of Israel their
government
>> people are said anything about them in particular I
am critical of their the government of Israel and I can criticize
any government I want to um in the entire world as well as our
own and a lot of >> yeah so their government I mean unfortunat
people get really assad about that it's like I'm sorry to say
like
it's a government I don't know. I don't think it's that bad.
But their government, no, she means she means the government
of Israel. >> at times I'm criticizing our own government
for failing the American people. And I think that needs to be
the focus and that's the most important thing people care about
is being able to afford groceries, housing, health insurance,
and having a good quality of >> Yeah. And I I hear you
saying you're not anti-Semitic and you've said it before and
you know some [clears throat] of the posts that you have put
up which you have apologized for certainly have uh tropes in
them that have been used historically against you. But I do want
to end this conversation with a question to you and that is do
you see a situation where you and President Trump can make up?
And if not, do you think you have a future in the GOP? >> Well,
I certainly hope that we can make up. And um there's, you know,
again, I can only speak for myself. I'm a Christian and one of
the most important parts of our faith is forgiveness. And that's
something I'm committed to. That's why I can easily come on your
show that is watched all over the world and I can say things
I'm sorry for and I can try to set an example of how I think
we should move forward as Americans. And so, of course, on my
end, I believe in that and I certainly hope to see that >> Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Green, I appreciate you coming on this morning.
Thank you so much.
>> Thank you, Dana.
>> Yeah. Just like there's nothing there. I'm sorry. There's
she she doesn't have like a group to belong to. If she's not
with Trump, she's got to walk back a bunch of the she said she's
she knows she's on the back foot in like eight different ways
right now. So, she's chilling. Okay. She's like waiting to see
where she can come up for error. She's like drowning right now.
She's she's in a cave. Okay. Okay, she tried to swim. She's in
some underwater cavern system and she went to swim between two
caves and she's stuck. Okay, she can't come up for air right
now. She's looking for the next opening. Where is it going to
be? Okay, let's see. There was the one more MTG tweet and then
I think we're moving forward. Let me see. I'll probably rewatch
the the Trump Marjorie Trader Green thing as well. Okay, after
that she says, "The hoax pizza deliveries have started now in
my house and family." She talks about how she's always been harassed
by people um on the left for defending Trump and now Trump is
calling her a traitor which is absolutely untrue and horrific.
Mark Leven has been calling me a traitor and so have other prominent
likely paid social media activists. This puts blood in the water
and creates a feeding frenzy and it could ultimately lead to
a harmful or even deadly outcome. Also, the timing of this just
happens to be days before we take the vote on releasing the Epstein
files. I love America and the American people, but and I swore
an oath to uphold the Constitution and always do so. I am not
a traitor. However, when the president of the United States irresponsibly
calls a member of Congress of his own party traitor, he is signaling
what must be done to a traitor. Actually, he's doing that when
he calls anyone a traitor. Marjorie, he's doing that when he
calls anyone a traitor. He does it all the time to the people
on the other side of the aisle. Uh, I think that's a fair criticism
that I didn't see this very very correctly. Actually, I think
this is a fair criticism. Shut up, [__] I fought
harder than anyone to help President Trump get elected and I
I I actually this is the one person where not one there's like
a handful of people where when she's like, "Oh, I didn't realize
what I was doing and I don't tr I'm sorry. I don't trust you.
I don't trust you. There's no reason to trust you. Leave politics
and then people will stop harassing you. Leave politics. Get
the [__] out. You're just a [__] grifter.
Leave. Go away. [__] off. Okay. I fought harder than
anyone to help President Trump get elected. And I support his
administration and the promises we made on the campaign. I am
a Republican in good standing and have paid all my dues to the
NRCC, National
Congressional Council or something. My voting record is one of
the most conservative voting records in Congress and I'm very
proud of that. The toxic and dangerous rhetoric in politics must
end. And we need to heal. We need healing in this country for
all Americans. And she did a Google AI pizza doxing. Pizza doxing
is what she looked up. The prank of ordering pizza to someone's
house for intimidation is known as pizza doxing.
Okay.
All right. You trust anyone in politics? I mean, not really,
but Marjorie is just like Marjory's far less trust. Like, I can
trust some people to act in their own interests, right? I can
trust some people through their actions. I can know their character,
and I can understand where they're going to go with things. Marjorie
is not like that. Marjorie, I have no idea which way she's going to
go tomorrow. She can do anything. She's unpredictable. She's
an unpredictable, unhinged.
Aha. All right. Let's one more truth social from President Trump.
As I said on Friday night aboard Air Force One to the fake news
media, House Republicans should vote to release the Epstein files
because we have nothing to hide and it's time to move on from
this Democrat hoax perpetrated by radical left lunatics in order
to deflect from the great success of the Republican party, including
our recent victory in the Democrat shutdown. The Department of
Justice has already turned over tens of thousands of pages to
the public on Epstein are looking at various Democrat operatives,
Bill Clinton, Reed Hoffman, Larry Summers, etc., and their relationship
to Epstein and the House Oversight Committee can have whatever
they are legally entitled to. I don't care. All I do care about
is Republic that Republicans get back on point, which is the
economy affordability where we are winning big. Our victory on
reducing inflation from the highest level in history to practically
nothing. Bringing down prices for the American people, delivering
historic tax cuts. Dude, shut up. Gaining trillions of dollars
in investment. This is not true. Do you guys remember when
what did Zuckerberg like lean over to Trump and he's like, "Oh,
I almost said like billion instead of million or something."
And Trump's like, I don't care. It's fine. Like, wasn't Zuck
Zuckerberg was basically talking about inflating how much he
was willing to invest? No. Okay. Anyway,
all of this stuff, transgender for everyone, stopping transgender
for everyone, and so much more. Nobody cared about it. Jeffrey
Epstein, when he was alive, and if the Democrats had anything,
they would have released it before our landslide election victory.
Some members of the Republican party are being used, and we can't
let that happen. Let's start talking about the Republican party's
record setting achievements and not fall into at the Epstein
trap, which is was which is actually a curse on the Democrats,
not us. Make American great. Make America great again.
Um, he's saying release whatever they're entitled to.
Uh, House Republicans should vote to release the Epstein files
because we have nothing to hide. I don't know what for what other
reason is he going after
That's like all it could possibly be, right? That's just clearly
the reason he's going after MTG. Why is he just saying this now?
Guys, you should just Why was he pressuring people not to do
it? Am I Am I misremembering? I could have sworn there was like
a bunch of like private pressure. He was calling Congress people
to vote no on this, right?
He was like actually trying to to pressure people into voting
against this. He brought Boowbert into the situation room last
week. Yeah. I don't know why he's trying to I don't know why
he's trying to get away from this now.
Well, sorry. I do know why. because he looks like an actual.
That's obviously why. But what the [__]
I got sent this earlier. Let's check it out. Okay. Trump's betrayal
of the America First movement.
Let's go,
brothers. I have been a Trump supporter for a very long time.
Even when things seem dark and bleak and everyone had turned
their back on Trump, they were looking at Dantis and
everyone else. Uh, you know, anyone was a more viable option
than Trump. I was still on the Trump train.
I just love that Tactical Templar is out here. Okay. while defending
Naktaku and also totally excoriating Donald Trump for his disgusting
phosmitism. Okay, Tactical Templar was ready to support Trump,
but then you saw how much of an ally Trump was to Israel and
he had to back out. All right, he had to back out. >> And
I got to say, it's been harder and harder to defend Trump
against some of his actions and some of his words.
He recently uh retracted his endorsement of Marjorie Taylor Green.
Now I have criticisms of Marjorie Taylor Green. I think a lot
of people do.
But
Marjorie Taylor Green introduced >> I have criticisms of
Marjorie Taylor Green. I think a lot of people do. Something
that I think is amazing. I am introducing a bill to end the mass
replacement [laughter] of American workers by aggressively phasing
out the H-1B program.
This is amazing.
This is genuinely amazing.
And Trump seems to be seething over this and her push for the
release of the Epstein Files. Now,
I think that Trump's handling of the Epstein Files is about >> What's
up, Ghoul? How's it going? >> Bad as you can imagine. >> Yes,
this is the most audibly fat person I've ever heard. I know.
No, no, no, no, no. You, Dude, I was watching this guy like two
months ago. The first video I watched, he like popped up in my
feed and I started watching him and the first video I watched,
he's like unable to stop the drool from folding back into his
mouth. It's like to talk, he has to hold his his head up at an
angle where like his drool drips back into his throat and it
constantly like creates this droplet like gargling sound. It's
[__] bizarre.
>> Including him losing his temper at a reporter. And usually
I love watching him lose his temper at reporters. It's
the way he lost his temper
is really weird. It It was really, really weird. I went over
on stream. He almost seemed to like lunge at her.
Like he almost seemed I I don't know if it's because of the way
the plane was moving. >> But he almost seemed to like lunge
[laughter] at her. He like poked at her. Like
it just seemed weird. The epscene stuff has him off his game,
but this H1B stuff
is terrible.
I don't know who's giving him this advice,
>> but optically this is very poor. And now
>> is coming out. >> Obviously, his donors, all of
Silicon Valley want the H-1B program to continue. Yeah, obviously
his donors are telling him, "Don't get rid of the H-1B >> They're
saying, "Well, I want to release the Epstein files. I wanna I
wanna phase out H-1B.
And MAGA
is torn between Trump saying, "Well, Marjorie Taylor Green is
not MAGA. I want to primary her. She's
And Marjorie Taylor Green saying, "Yeah, I want to get rid of
H-1B.
I'm I'm going to be um introducing a
Very interesting.
My dear fellow Americans, I'm introducing a bill to completely
eliminate the H-1B visa program, which has been riddled with
fraud and abuse and has been displacing American workers for
decades.
There will only be one exemption in my bill, and it will allow
for a 10,000 per year cap on visas issued to medical professionals
like doctors and nurses who provide life-saving care to Americans.
However, even this 10,000 per year cap will be phased out over
10 years to allow us time to [clears throat] build our own pipeline
of American doctors and physicians. My bill will also restore
the original intent of the visa for it to be temporary. These
visas were intended to fulfill a specialty occupational need
at a given time. People should not be allowed to come and live
here forever. We thank them for their expertise, but we also
wish them well so they may return to their home country. My bill
will take away the pathway to citizenship, forcing visa holders
to return home when their visa expires in order to build our
pipeline of American doctors and medical professionals. My bill
will also prohibit Medicare funded residency
>> Like I understand people defending immigration, especially
H-1B immigration. I feel like it does cause, you know,
I I think there's a flood of tech workers that don't need to
be replaced. I think all these companies are laying off tons
and tons of tech workers. There is no reason to have an H-1B
program to cut costs in America. These people are already not
hiring in America. There's no reason to help them cut costs further
in America, right? There's a massive supply of workers. I don't
think I just totally disagree. You could have I believe there's
a visa type above H-1B,
but I mean that's one industry and that's my personal experience.
So I it hardly amounts to hey we need to get rid of all H-1Bs
for all industries >> programs from admitting non-citizen
medical students into their programs.
Just last year alone there were over 9,000 doctors in the US
who graduated from medical school but were left without a residency
placement. Meanwhile, in 2023 alone, there were over 5,000 foreignb
born doctors who received residency spots. This is entirely unfair
and it's America last. >> Yeah, I realize that the evidence
is not great. I know that, Madison.
I know that. I'm telling you that the evidence is not great based
on the past couple years. And I'm telling you right now that
like mass layoffs are happening all over tech right now. And
and I feel like there's no reason to argue that there aren't
talented people here, but we we can keep I well I mean it's not
my country. It doesn't really matter, but I think I think it's
difficult to argue for like H1B need right now.
>> My bill will help mitigate the shortage of doctors.
And >> this is basically you have to offset this a little
bit. Uh Ghoul, it's funny that you're mentioning this. Fuentes
had a rant that um [clears throat] that I really like I thought
like I was like, "Oh, this is going to be a real problem." This
is probably when I realized that he was going to be a real problem.
I want to say it was in 2023, but he started talking about how
much like a degree costs and it's like you get this degree, you
start your job, you get two years in, you get laid off, you get
replaced by five different Indians who can work for your wage,
right, combined. And you realize you're saddled with all of this
debt. Your country doesn't make anything. all of your all of
your income is from AI and financial like uh financial jobs and
it's like okay our economy is not real uh we don't make anything
I have all of this debt I don't have a job anymore what what
is what is the American dream right there's like a lot of things
you can put together I just butchered it horribly but there's
a lot of things you can put together there to convince people
that they're totally and to vote for whatever the whatever whatever
fascist is offering them the best lies right like they just think
they're totally
Honestly, I feel like you're getting pretty close to the point
where you could argue on like
straight up imperialism, straight up resource extraction. We're
going to go take over some countries and start like enslaving
people. I feel like you're you're getting to the point where
people will vote for that. I mean, not actually 5 years away.
It's getting fast. He's getting here faster though. Okay. and
nurses in our country the shortage that we face while at the
same time serve as an off-ramp from our reliance on foreign workers
by allowing us time to fill our residency programs with American
doctors. Now, this will completely end the H-1B visa program
in all other sectors in the job in the job force and in the workforce.
This is America first. It's time to put American citizens first
instead of foreigners first. And this has gone on and this has
been an abuse for far too long. Americans deserve a future. They
deserve a chance. And I believe Americans are the most talented
people in the world, the most creative, and I want them to have
their American dream. Thank
>> I couldn't have said it better myself. That is absolutely
stunning and brave and [laughter] Dude, his voice hits so hard
right after listening to MTG somehow. Like she has at least eight
times the testosterone in her system that he does. It's wild.
I'm not I'm not being facicious. That is incredible. That is
what Trump should be saying.
That should be coming out of Trump's mouth. But Trump
has been saying that Americans are incompetent. Americans are
lazy. Americans are stupid. >> We're trying to prove him
correct or
Trump has been saying that Americans are lazy and Americans are
stupid and Americans are fat. Oh, wait. He didn't say the last
part. What?
And I mean, what a what a dismal failure
as a presidency
to say that the American people
are too stupid
to do these jobs that you have to bring in foreign labor. You
know, >> I mean, Americans are lazy. The people in North
America are lazy. We went through COVID on all of this borrowed
money. We got used to like ordering food, not doing any of our
own chores, not doing any of our own work, barely working from
home. Okay, we need a we need a cultural reset, but we're not
we're not worthless. Okay,
>> you also do have to bring in talent when a country No,
you don't. No, you don't. >> Donald Trump is once again
facing the wrath of his own MAGA base for essentially claiming
that American workers are not sufficiently talented. And we're
going to hear more from some of those outraged right rightwingers
soon. But first, Jenk, your two cents. >> Here's what I
love. That finally uh Trump's voters are beginning to see the
Trump that we all know, which is an idiot who is part of the
elites and the establishment and will just say stupid stuff right
off the top of his head. >> I swear I swear to God, Jank
almost cried right there when he said establishment. The elites
and part of the establishment.
part of the elites and the establishment and was just >> I
swear to God there was like a catch in his voice right there.
He was like about to cry. >> Say stupid stuff right off
the top of his head. >> Well, I mean, first of all, Jen,
you're in no position to be lecturing anyone about just saying
stupid stuff off the top of your head. You once advocated that
you should be able to pleasure animals
uh and have sex with them. No, we don't see Trump the way that
you see Trump.
It just happens to be that on this issue,
>> he is not acting in accordance with what America first
is. And yes, it was a boneheaded thing. However,
JD Vance said the opposite.
So, this isn't, oh, MAGA's MAGA is turning on Trump. No, we are
criticizing Trump as we have when Trump came out with his initial
H1B. >> Listen, if that if that animal was anthropomorphic
and just had cat ears,
Tactical Templar would be down for it. >> Statement with
Elon and VC,
Trump was criticized for that, too.
When Trump makes a mistake,
we've hold his feet to the fire. We criticize him thoroughly
because the hope is to push him more towards America first.
Whereas his current policy
is not America first. It's not MAGA.
So Jenk is
as always being a bloiated bombastic bigot
and just >> damn love the aliteration. belching out these
ridiculous lines because that's
that that's what comes familiar to him.
>> Bloiating bombastic bigot.
>> But I think it's important to understand we can criticize
Trump
when he up and does things wrong. But it does Oh no, you're saying
Trump we always have. No, you accuse Trump of all manner of impropriety.
You tried to throw him in
You have no leg to stand on as it relates to this. >> Before
they never caught him, I'll tell you why they're catching him
now. And even Laura Ingram caught him, as you're about to see.
>> Now, during this unusually contentious interview with
Laura Ingram, Donald Trump bragged about how fabulously the economy
is doing in his eyes in large >> Was that like a weird
transition? Is he is Chank like reacting to his own intern segment
or something? That didn't feel like a natural transition. [clears throat]
Is he like providing commentary over top of a video that like
an intern for TYT did >> during this unusually contentious?
>> Sorry, I I went back, but it's like he just introduced
a segment and then this guy introduces the segment again >> interview
with Laura Ingram. Donald Trump bragged about how fabulously
the economy is doing in his eyes in large part thanks to his
tariff policies. That's when Laura Ingram brought up H-1B visas,
which allows skilled foreign workers to come to the United States
temporarily. And Trump completely stepped in it. Take a look.
>> I'm now at almost $18 trillion in 9 months. That's the
biggest in the history of the world. China's never done it. never
done anywhere near that. And all that money is coming in. It's
investment. It's building auto plants. It's building AI plants
where, by the way, we're leading China by a lot on AI.
>> We have potentially the greatest econ.
But we have when these things open up, there's never going to
be a country like what we have right now. The Republicans have
to talk about it. >> And does that mean the H-1B visa thing
will not be a big priority for your administration? If you want
to raise wages for American workers, you can't flood the country.
>> Wait, wait, wait. AI is doing a bunch of jobs, right?
A bunch of white collar jobs replacing white collar work. Is
there a lot of white collar work going on in places outside of
America? Like
I feel like I feel like you're basically investing in outsourcing
that can be done. It's like paying for white collar workers to
be replaced in the same way that factory workers were, right?
By automated just by automation or they the way they would be
if you put the factories in America. Like there's there's some
comparison there,
right? Or at least that's the hope. I don't even know that there's
solid evidence that people are being made substantially more
productive by AI yet. I feel like I feel like the evidence is
still out on that >> country with with tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands of foreign >> You also do have
to bring in talent when a country talented people. No, you don't.
No, you don't. We don't have talented people. >> No, you
don't have you don't have certain talents and you have to people
have to learn. You can't take people off an unemployment like
an unemployment line and say, "I'm going to put you into a factory.
We're going to make missiles or I'm going to put >> How
did we ever do it before?" Now, the H-1B visa debate caused a
stir early in Trump's term when you had his tech oligarch friends
like Elon Musk arguing that there should be more H-1B visas arguing
in favor of them, but then his MAGA OGs like Steve Bannon arguing
against them. By the way, Musk's Tesla allegedly laid off thousands
of their skilled American workers in 2024 and replaced them with
cheaper foreign work. Dude, how does how does anybody look at
JD Vance and they go, "Oh, this is the populace guy." Like, I
I have a feeling that Tactical Templar would love JD Vance. How
do any of these people look at JD Vance and think he's not going
to just advocate for maximum H-1Bs, maximum worker replacement,
just everything to keep to like power the
the
continual
uh what would you call it? Like accumulation that's going on
at the top. That's that's who he is. That's who he's hired by.
That's who he's trained by. That's the group he's a part of.
And there's so many people. I'm sure this Tactical Templar guy,
Asol, all these people love JD Vance.
Why? How? How do you not see that he's just their guy? Workers
using H1B visas. Trump tried to plate his MAGA base by signing
an executive order that instituted a $100,000
fee for companies to obtain the visas back in September. But
now he's thoroughly enraged them again by insult.
>> His son's name is literally vagueing
American workers. Marjorie Taylor Green took issue with his comments
writing on X. I believe in the American people. I'm one of you.
I believe you are good, talented, creative, intelligent, hardworking,
and want to achieve. I'm sol. This is the problem with populism.
Okay. Trump was this guy where he was like, I'm I'm so on your
side. I'm even more on your side than everybody else. Right?
That's what he always tell people. I'm going to get your jobs
back and I'm actually going to punish the people who took your
jobs from you. And now he's like got all these tech oligarchs
who are funding him and he's like, well, you know, H1Bs, we need
more people. Maybe I can't punish all these. Maybe I can't just
be all the way on your side. And immediately a bunch of people
try to flank him from like the populist direction. And it's like,
oh, all the times I lied and said I'd help people. It turns out
if I stop lying,
somebody else is just willing to start lying. It's almost like
I just have to keep lying forever now.
Has anybody ever experienced this before? Yes. Everybody who
starts lying about the things they can achieve for others. Literally
every single one of them. Those lies just start to snowball on
you and and they run away. They run out of control. Solidly against
you being replaced by foreign labor like with H1Bs.
I am solidly against allowing foreign students into our colleges
and universities like 600,000 Chinese students just to financially
prop them up. If they fail, they fail. The system in place isn't
helping our young people.
>> she's right.
She's right. And the reality is that Marjorie Taylor Green
is behaving more in line with America First and MAGA than Trump
is. It's just an observable fact. This is America
>> Okay. While that may be true, this kind these kinds
of lies where you're going to, you know, be nivist, you're going
to be protectionist, they are America first. Yes. Um I don't
think they matter. I straight up don't.
I think
the uh it's hard to say for sure. for Marjorie Taylor Green.
I feel like the the true populist people in her in her state
who just follow the populist message wherever it goes, who are
like up to date, would actually know that she's having this fight
with Trump. Those are few and far between. Most of it's just
a cult of personality around Trump. Most people will just continue
to go with him until it becomes apparent, until there's something
like a vote, some policy that gets passed that totally them.
I feel like it's just going to be apparent that that they'll
just go with Trump.
600,000 Chinese students. Well, I assume the funny thing is is
I assume that those Chinese students are the same thing that
would happen in Canada where Chinese students just fund Canadian
schools, right? So, it's cheap for everybody else. Yes, a lot
of them are spies. Yes, it's true. But they just fund Canadian
schools. That's what they do. They they pay like five to 10 times
the tuition.
I think it it's probably going to be the same in the US. No.
>> Saying no, we don't want such 100,000 Chinese students.
No, we don't want foreign labor. No, we don't think that Americans
are
and can't do the work. No, you should. >> Yeah. Yeah, that
is that is actually true. Porter Beller, you you guys do get
kind of on both ends there. At least in Canada, they come and
spy, but they have to pay to like fund all of our schools. I
don't know what America's getting out of it. You guys already
pay insane amounts to have like football teams or something.
It makes no sense to me. be incentivizing American citizens
to like like with ICE
like Trump this is probably one of his biggest blunders that
I've seen
because it fundamentally
fails to read >> this is what happens in Canada Moonray
Murray I don't know if you're talking about the states too this
is absolutely what happens in Canada I have a friend who goes
back to China like every six months and just brings a suitcase
full of money back with him like every time
like he brings a suitcase back of valuables. Like there's like
some it's it's a fairly high cap. It's like an unsuspectedly
or you wouldn't suspect how high the cap is. It's like $20,000
or something $25,000. No, there's like a cap on how much he could
bring back. He brings the maximum amount of cash back with him
every single time. It's very funny
because he used to work at BU. He was like a software engineer
at BYU and he was like one of their top senior engineers there
and he came to work at a company I worked at really smart guy
really really talented guy obviously and he made a money at BU
because he was there very early and then he came over to Canada
and he just tell me about how he's bringing like socks full of
cash cuz he needs to like he needs it not to get found by people
who are corrupt
but he he wasn't like sneaking through customs. He like declared
it a customs when he came in or so he said but he needed to not
get grabbed by people in China. Yeah. Very funny stories from
that guy.
>> Bro, the Chinese work culture is crazy at their tech
companies though. Apparently he used to work like 17our shifts
and they would have just like beds under their desks literally.
Like they would have beds on their under their desks. They would
just work like crazy shifts all the time.
This was a This is one of Trump's biggest blunders,
demonstrating you don't have faith in the American people.
That is
And Trump is going to pay a heavy political price for that.
And with the Epstein files, I don't know if he's going to be
able to win back
a lot of the people that he's losing. Because if I'm
looking at this and going, "Trump, you [__] up."
You know, it's bad. Like, genuinely,
I've been a Trump supporter for a long time,
>> bro. I
You know what should actually change all these people's minds?
Okay. Do you know what should change their minds? The fact that
Trump decided he was going to roll back tariffs on beef and a
couple other things to try to reduce prices. That is an obvious
and clear admission that tariffs raise prices.
Oh, I'm going to roll back certain tariffs. Why? Because prices
are too high. Wait, what? I thought tariffs didn't raise prices.
>> But I've always maintained that if Trump up or if he
betrayed America first that I'd be there to criticize it, and
he definitely has in innumerable ways >> She's referring
to another moment in the interview there where Laura Ingram challenged
Trump's plan to bring thousands of Chinese students into the
country. He defended the policy and said, "Don't forget MAGA
was my idea. MAGA was nobody else's idea. I know what MAGA wants
better."
>> No, you don't.
You didn't make MAGA. MAGA made you.
That that that is a total and complete inversion.
>> It is an inversion,
but there has been nobody else. There is nobody else who's the
same.
So while that is an inversion, he has earned the right to I guess
throw that inversion in people's face and not >> you did
not make MAGA. MAGA made you the
I It's crazy. It really is.
We like Trump being uh being
but this is on another this is on another level. Trump.
Trump is the bed. Um, this is bad optics,
bad messaging.
I I don't even know what you make of this at this point.
You know, do I still support Donald Trump? Yeah, because I think
he does have a lot of good things that he's doing, of course.
But at the same time, I'm going to criticize Trump heavily
when he does things that's wrong in the hope that we push him
towards being more more conservative,
being more in line with America first than anybody else. But
based on the responses from dozens of other MAGA [clears throat]
figures, I'm not so sure that's true. Anthony Sabatini, a Republican
politician from Florida, said, "This is insane. We are going
to lose the midterms so badly. We've never seen an administration
crash and burn in its first year so badly for no reason other
than to appease donors and special interests. Trump has." Is
that true? I feel like Trump's done a lot of crazy just purely
for himself.
Like the all of the tariff stuff, that's none of his special
interests or donors are asking for that, right? I guarantee you
every single donor he has is begging him to roll those tariffs
back.
>> Surrounded himself with the worst people. Tim P, right-wing
podcaster, added, "Don't worry. Trump is bringing in more H1Bs
to make sure our young people are blanked."
Conservative activist Mike Cernovich said Trump broke everyone's
heart with this line about the American workforce and H1Bs.
He also accused Trump of only listening to donors, which Candace
Owens co-signed. And on his show today, Steve Bannon said the
H-1B program, >> this is actually really funny. This is
really funny. Trump Trump is operating from the rare position
of
like speaking reality to his his base and his base gets to like
treat him the way he treats everybody else.
[laughter] He's like sitting there. He like has the facts on
his side for the first time in forever and everybody's just going
to be like you're bought and paid for
you. Is indentured servitude to compete against Americans and
take jobs for lower wages as usual. Now the rest of Trump's cabinet
is trying to do some damage control. Here's Treasury Secretary
Scott Bessant insisting that foreign workers are just a temporary
fix. Take a look.
>> I think the president >> Okay. Hey, roll back
the pathway to
>> Vision here is to bring in overseas workers where these
jobs went >> who have skills >> who have the skills
three, five, seven
>> Like unfortunately,
this smacks of like stupid when you've worked in this industry
and you've seen like where outsourcing has gotten some companies
like no company benefits from outsourcing outside of the the
like budgetary, you know, outside of their balance sheet. on
the balance sheet. It looks great. In terms of productivity,
it's
awful. It's just terrible. Okay.
And everybody's like, "Oh, well, we outsourced all the jobs over
there. We need to bring the workers over here." Wait, what [__]
are you saying? What about the people who had their jobs outsourced?
How the [__] are you? Are you serious? >> Years
to train the US workers, then they can go home. The US workers
fully take over. So do you have do you want to understand the
concern that some people have? Hey, an American could have that
job. Why you give it to America? >> But American can't
have that job because specific skills because we haven't built
ships in the US for years. We haven't built semiconductors.
So you this >> okay I so don't put it don't no H-1Bs for
accounting or software. Isn't that like 90% of H1Bs
software workers
accountants?
Yeah. every anybody who's not in those two fields, just get rid
of those H-1Bs.
>> The idea of overseas partners coming in, teaching American
workers, then returning home, that's a home run. >> Jen,
what do you make of this? >> Yeah, it's so complicated.
So, Trump's reaction is not complicated. I'll come back to that.
Uh, but the H-1B visa issue is complicated. Why? Uh, [snorts]
it it [clears throat] definitely has a use. It definitely has
a value. Uh, but has it been abused? Yes. So, is it only used
for uh foreigners to come in, teach Americans a skill set, and
then leave? No way. They're totally making that up. That's actually
a rare instance, right? Well, yeah, because he's not talking
about it the way that it's been used. He's talking about it in
the way that he's, you know,
translating the way that Trump wants to use it.
But no, has that is not the way that it's been. Jenk is actually
right when it comes to that. It has not been used in that way.
But that's Trump saying that's how he wants to use it. Now, I
think that's fundamentally wrong. I think that that is incorrect.
You can train you have people in the United States
that can train people in the United States on this. You don't
need foreign labor. You don't need third worlders
to >> Like if you want to argue we need H-1Bs to pull a
bunch of Taiwanese people in cuz we need everybody from TSMC,
then that's like you you just have a different visa category
for that. Obviously, you've got like a talented visa category.
They they just lie about what H-1Bs are for like all the time.
>> Come here. You don't. It is outrageous to say so. >> Why
don't they start talking about how like brain drain from other
countries is good no matter what? It just keeps other countries
behind. I guess that sounds bad. That's like the other side of
this is what I suspect in some ways is like, hey, if we just
get, you know, educated people from other countries. We just
get the best educated people from those countries, then that's
going to have positive like long-term effects for the economy.
That's probably true, right? But they don't say anything like
that. It's like that would at least come close to being a sensible
answer to me. you are trying to sell the American people on have
I seen uh and I'm not sure that it was in regards to H-1B visas
but uh but a similar uh topic where America a friend of mine
uh taught
his replacements that were coming in from India how to do their
jobs and then
>> I did this I totally did this when I was at a big tech
company I got laid off I got laid off and They they laid me off
and they said, "You can't have your severance. We'll give you
6 months severance, but you can't have it unless you stay for
3 months and train your replacement." And then after 3 months,
they hadn't been able to hire my replacement from Mexico or India.
So, they asked me to stay for three more months and and but that
time they couldn't make my my what do you call it? Oh, they asked
me to stay on for three more months. I said I would stay on for
three more months just guarantee my severance. like if you guys
cuz my severance was basically contingent on me remaining employed
there. But I was like just give me my severance now or guarantee
my severance so that you can't take it away and then I'll do
that. And they said no. I'm like well you just give me my seance
then off. And so I took the six month seance and left. But they
kept me on. I didn't even have a job. They kept me on and were
like, "Hey, you could chill for like a couple weeks and then
in about, you know, I think I think they were like in, you know,
within two or three weeks, we're going to have somebody here
and you're going to have to teach the person how to do your job."
And they didn't even get me to do stuff for the first month.
I think I was on like pager duty to make sure stuff wasn't down,
right? So, if like stuff went down, I had to go answer those
things, but I think that's all they had me doing. And then after
maybe a couple a couple weeks, they're like, "Hey, could you
look at like this bug fix or that bug fix?" And I was like, "Oh,
yeah. do that and they pay me like a money and the whole point
was I was supposed to train like a replacement from Mexico or
Pakistan that they couldn't even find to hire and then I found
out like
maybe like a month later
they hired back like one of the guys from the team because like
somebody who' been there for years before me they let off like
my entire team but they hired back somebody because they literally
just couldn't find replacements.
It's like so goofy. It's so [__] >> And those
replacements took the jobs and he didn't have a choice. They
were going to be let go and there incentives etc. Somebody was
going to teach them anyway. My point >> I wonder I wonder
if this guy worked at the same company I worked at or if this
is just a really common thing >> is it usually works in
re reverse. They don't usually have cheap labor teach more expensive
labor. They usually have expensive labor teacher labor and then
use cheaper labor for the rest of the time. Right. So that don't
get tricked by Scott Bessent and his nonsense propaganda
um or anything he ever says. Okay. So
Jake is bombastic,
but he is correct.
He is correct.
Very rarely do you have
expensive labor cheap uh teach labor so that cheap labor can
then go and teach expensive labor.
Yeah, it it is now. I don't agree with the Young Turks on >> said
Jenk Jenk
or boy Jenkuger
Jenk weager
>> nearly anything as it relates to
I think that a lot of these people are [clears throat] malicious
bad actors acting in bad faith.
I think that their analysis of Trump I mean it speaks for itself.
I still sometimes watch the video of Jenkuger and the Young Turks
crashing out at Trump's victory in 2016.
But
the fact is that in this instance, he's correct
that it is not logical to say, "Oh, we're just going to bring
in people
to train Americans." No, you're not. And we know that you're
not.
So, don't lie to us. >> All right. Now, uh, but at the
same time, there are some places where H-1B visas definitely
make sense. I would not be in the camp of no, no, we got to ban
these foreigners and they're of no value to us at all and we
don't need any stinking foreigners around here. Yeah, Jake, you
like that? You've lost me and you lost everyone else. Yeah. No,
we don't need any stinking foreigners here. We we don't need
any people here from the third world.
You know, we we have a uh we have reached our quota
on anti-American
uh gifters
who are abusing the system and have no allegiance to this country.
>> Did he just say gifas? Gas
gas guas.
>> so gas. We don't need no gas. anti-American
u gifas
>> who are abusing the system and have no allegiance to
this country.
>> yeah, I hope that Trump gets his [__]
He's uh he's completely
out of his mind on this. He's wrong. Hopefully somebody
sets him straight, but who knows?
Anyway, brothers, I want to thank you for watching. I want to
thank you for supporting the channel, and I'll see you next time.
Wow. Wow. Wow.